do you need some help
i could do her hair whose hair
extensions were so hated
the actor actually ripped them out of
their head on set
we never would have thought the wigs
costumes and prosthetics used in the
twilight franchise could be so painful
but actors on set would say otherwise
anna kendrick once described it
as a nightmare which actor could barely
see with painful contacts in their eyes
let's have a look nothing in twilight is
easy
the legs bella had after breaking her
spine in the twilight saga were gaunt
looking prosthetics
made for stewart to wear while filming a
prop table was built so stewart's real
legs could be hidden away underneath
under the table the actress's legs were
in sweatpants
hot and extremely stiff from being stuck
still for so long since she had to do
all her performing from the waist up
even getting in and out of the
contraption was a hassle and stuart
needed to have
extra hands to help her maneuver the
tricky set piece looking down at
you know really flimsy legs is
strange throughout breaking dawn part
one bella's body underwent some serious
changes
and to help bring the looks to life a
combo of cgi and prosthetics reused
the prosthetics added to her face to
make her ears look bigger and eyes
sunken in
emphasizing how thin she was took a
grueling three
hours to apply before filming stewart
had to deal with a lot of extra weight
and discomfort while wearing the
as the actress called it inhumanely
large stomach prosthetic
she was totally shocked when she saw
just how big the belly prosthetic was
too weird for the twilight movies
pattinson sported his vampire look with
loads of makeup to make him look pale
and light-colored contacts as well
those contact lenses drove pattinson
crazy
he wore them for three consecutive
months and claimed his eyes
never got used to it in fact he said it
felt like he had sand in his eyes the
entire time
even getting them into his eyes was a
terrible experience
pattinson used to have to go through 20
minutes doing each eye and from the very
start
they'd just fold in his eyes anyway
pattinson blames the lenses for making
it difficult for him to perform and
express emotion
since the actor said his vision was so
impeded he could only really see two
orange blobs did you get contacts
no kristen stewart was one of the many
actors who had to wear contact lenses
for her role when filming twilight
movies
stuart didn't have a choice in the
matter but from day one
she was looking forward to the day that
she got to say goodbye to them
stewart noted the yellow contacts as the
absolute worst ones since they severely
limited the ability to see
and made her feel almost claustrophobic
it's no secret that robert pattinson
hated the orange wig he had to wear
while doing reshoots of breaking dawn
part 2.
the so-called frankenstein wig was the
result of six different pieces combined
however this isn't the first time the
actor dealt with an irritating hairpiece
when pattinson first booked the role the
plan was actually to have them in hair
extensions
to bring the timeless look of edward to
life pattinson was not a fan of the idea
at all and one day when he was wearing
them he literally
ripped them out of his hair on set after
that
the shaggy vampire look was born
your skin is pale white and ice cold
it wasn't just contact lenses that were
a nuisance for stewart to wear
she also had to deal with painful hair
extensions
the actress didn't feel comfortable with
them at all but
had to endure them to bring the perfect
look to screen
in an interview once the actress said
she described that time in her life
simply as
really uncomfortable hair extensions
that is saying a lot yeah i guess
taylor lautner had to wear an extremely
long black wig which he was
very excited to get to shed lautner said
the wig was so uncomfortable because it
was itchy
hot and just overall annoying even the
look of it bothered the actor and he
said he didn't recognize himself when he
had it on
the wig turned out to be an
inconvenience for a lot of people
going so far is to ruin shots regularly
the hair was so long and unruly it often
wound up blowing into lautner's face
one scene in new moon was really
dampened by the wig
when he was meant to kiss bella his hair
blew right into his mouth and got caught
leaving him to spit out his hair right
before kissing her
the last day they had to use the wig
lautner ripped it off
and the entire crew celebrated since it
had been such an annoyance for everyone
after filming the actor turned down the
offer to keep the wig but has since
confessed he wishes he'd held onto it
you cut your hair off in order to
achieve nikki reed's blonde hair for the
films
the actress had to undergo an intense 36
hours of dyeing her hair blonde
followed by bleaching treatments every
other day
all this painful treatment destroyed her
hair to the point that it actually
started falling out reed had to stop the
intense dying treatment
so thankfully she got to switch to a wig
for the rest of the saga
that was all that thing was awake she's
been wearing a wig ever since
new moon among the many twilight actors
who had to wear contacts
was elizabeth racer as esme cullen the
actress called them beyond annoying as
well as excruciating
the final battle was one of the most
painful scenes for the actor to endure
all the snow falling which was actually
tiny bits of paper
started getting caught inside her
eyelids causing them to swell up
a lot of regrets the august wedding
well let's just say it didn't feel
anything like the warm summer month when
they were filming the scene
the actors struggled to get through
filming as they shivered in their summer
formal wear
between takes all the performers huddled
together cuddling under blankets and
parkas just trying to keep warm
anna kendrick was only on set a few
times but she didn't escape filming in
chilly weather
the actress described the experience as
absolutely miserable
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding when
edward and bella had their prom
it wasn't actually the warm weather most
people get to have
the actors were freezing cold wearing
only formal wear while filming and were
quickly covered with parkas and blankets
as soon as the cameras stopped
see you're dancing he may have been
working out intensely and sticking to a
strict diet but he still didn't look the
part
the actor ended up needing to wear heel
lifts inside his shoes so he looked
taller than christian stewart
for me kristen has been absolutely
amazing to work with
in a deleted scene from eclipse bella
and jacob were seen growing old together
both actors had a lot of prosthetics and
aging makeup applied
which is far from a comfortable
experience what made it worse is that
afterwards the team saw the results of
the prosthetics
and they decided it looked too awkward
to be convincing so the whole process
turned out to be for nothing
it makes me sick let's take a moment to
acknowledge
kristen stewart's incredibly awkward wig
and breaking dawn
her hair was cut to be a much shorter
and edgier style after filming the
runaways so
the hair department provided her with a
wig to suit the character
however no one noticed until much after
the fact that the wig looked
very strange and mismatched from stuart
and the film in general
this wig was memorable but definitely
not for the right reasons
really i'm not i'm fine don't say you're
fine
when lautner was playing his wolf self
he really stepped into the role
but was a lot less furry than we'd
expect
instead of having a double step in and
take over for the scene that was going
to have cgi added anyway
lautner himself went into full wolf mode
and even bent his head down for bella to
pat
this was all while lautner was in a very
awkward tight
full body head included grey leotard
definitely not nearly as intimidating as
what we saw in the film
some of you are gonna get hurt it's no
surprise
that in these movies filled with
vampires and werewolves
there would be some uncomfortable
costumes but who knew
one franchise could have so many painful
wigs
the fact that the cast members and
extras also so often had to film in such
chilly weather conditions is pretty
impressive
we definitely feel for them which
situation sounded most uncomfortable to
you